it might it must be nice to be magic
johnson in los angeles that must be a
good everywhere you go it's the coolest
thing it's the coolest thing yeah it's
just like being conan you know uh and
thank you to boston thank you
[Laughter]
no in boston they're like you left screw
you
how come you didn't stay in boston
that's what they're like in boston you
know that but you're still a boston fan
though yeah i am a boston celtics fan i
have to tell you yes i i can't change my
allegiance that's where i'm from i must
stay and you always have told me that
you you like larry bird more than me
i i got it i got it i call you i still
come on the show anyway
you make it sound like i call you up at
home i like larry bird more than you
i don't do that sometimes it comes up in
conversation yes i love you i admire you
i think you're one of the greatest
players of all time but i i grew up and
uh we were so don't apologize i won't
apologize
okay
this is exciting that now you're a
dodgers owner okay which is this is
exciting stuff and i'm curious have you
ever played baseball in your life for
about uh 20 minutes
yeah went out for the team for our first
game
how old are you when this is happening
now i'm what ten eleven yeah in the
league yeah and i did okay in the field
yeah but now it's time for us to back
and conan a brother is not used to a
fastball coming
at his head and not knowing that it's
gonna break inside right right so i was
bailing out oh you were stepping out
every time every time right and strike
one strike two strike three i was out so
the coach called me over and said
i don't think this game is for you
and i said you're right i was gonna quit
anyway so
i just that's great that's great though
that you you knew to like okay i'm going
into an uh were there other sports you
tried afterwards no i played field
hockey
well we ice skated in michigan so i'm
playing i
i can imagine yeah yeah it's so funny
because you'd think great athletes would
be great at any sport i remember once
years ago i played in a charity softball
event with nick's great patrick ewing
yes tara he was terrible just i'm sorry
to sell that man out but he was terrible
the ball would come his way and be like
i couldn't do it it just wasn't his
sport no you know everybody can't play
every sport you know and so i understand
that i and plus i'd rather be the owner
than the player so yeah good very nice
well
have you got ideas on how to spice up uh
baseball do you want to make any changes
or anything you want to do with the game
of baseball that you think might add
some excitement to it because your
nickname showtime you make it you it's
fast paced it moves right isn't baseball
must seem so slow to you well it is slow
but also it's family driven so it's fun
and it's nice being outside but if you
got some suggestions i would definitely
take them i'm glad you asked here's what
i think
hear me out hear me out i think when you
hit the ball you should have the choice
of either running to first base or to
third
once you commit to a direction you have
to keep going in that direction so you'd
have players crossing each other between
third and second also after you hit the
ball you hang onto the bat
you get to use it twice in the course of
the game
to clear out the path ahead of you
this is a much more exciting game is it
not what i'm describing
you're gonna take bud seely and get him
out yeah and name you the new
commissioner
there's also an idea between third and
home there's a slip and slide
you just slide i do like that okay good
good